hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my legends of tomorrow finale
video I know you have a whole bunch of
questions about the big twist and what's
going on with season 3 so I'll try to
explain everything just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet if
you're new to the channel I do DC and
Marvel videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'm even doing a reverse flash ring
giveaway that I'll explain at the end of
the video but there are a whole bunch of
Doctor Who level crazy twists with time
travel so I'll explain how some of the
dead characters are still alive in the
difference between Rick and Morty theory
of the multiverse and multiple
dimensions in the way the show is
treating it because within legends of
tomorrow even though we've done
multiverse with the flash they've only
been in this universe so like when all
the reverse flashes showed up later in
the episode those are all from different
points in his own timeline they're not
from different dimensions so I'll
explain that when we get to that part of
my top 10 WTF list so here we go number
10 unshrinking the Waverider you get
heatwave shaking it just a lot of comedy
of them using Ray's suit to power back
up and we see a whole bunch of STAR Labs
as they crash it through the roof it
looks a lot like season 1 STAR Labs from
the flash the way they light it the way
everything looks I guess you could say
that's an Easter Egg for reverse-flash
from season 1 even though technically
that was Harrison wells reverse-flash in
the way they ended the episode was
almost exactly like the reverse flashes
death during flash season 1 finale so
there are a lot of parallels in this
version of reality that reverse-flash
created for himself and that season 1
version of the show so great exit number
9 breaking all the Doctor Who rules of
time-travel so here's where we get to
like the big cornerstone of the show do
not interact with yourself from another
period in time this may have been a rule
that you forgot about they mentioned it
a couple times through the episode and
it's a rule that the doctor on Doctor
Who breaks all the time if you've never
watched Doctor Who don't worry about it
it's a show that's predicated on the
idea of someone who has control over
time travel and misuses it all the time
so at the same time he is the antagonist
and the hero of the show like everybody
hates them even his own people so the
same thing happened with alleges in the
episode they're the heroes but they also
create their own biggest problems with
the time storm which is what happened
when they went back and interacted with
themselves so the beauty of this though
is that number 8 we get to watch reverse
/ rip ray Palmer's out right out of his
chest without missing a beat it's so
great and it's graphic in a way that I
don't think we've seen the flash in a
while you've seen people die on the
flash but usually they do it in a very
bloodless way that's usually part of
network television just can't show that
much blood Stephen Amell complains about
it all the time because arrows such a
dark show he's like I would love if we
could use more blood so this version of
the reverse flash is the version from
the future that just followed them back
after he realized what they did so he's
breaking all these time-travel rules -
so just in the back of your mind if
you're like hey wait a minute
isn't the black flash still locked up
isn't he going to be coming for him it's
just one of those hanging plot threads
you get more and more excited about like
you know they have to address it at some
point they teed it up in last week's
episode like he's locked up in there
somehow he's got to get out no comic
book villain is ever this powerful
without getting the rug pulled out from
under them so the next big twist number
seven legends vs. legends they sort of
figure out what the future versions of
themselves are doing and they face-off
they wind up on the ship together that
creates the time storm there's a lot of
awkward comedy heat wave versus heat
wave I wonder what you would look like
with all your teeth punched out they
answer all the awkward questions about
the versions of them that aren't there
like hey what what happened to me from
the other timeline so Martin Stein is
still in the future working for
reverse-flash they say he's good as dead
rages got his heart ripped out in vixen
was killed by captain Colt so there's
sort of that awkward long pause and you
start to wonder if they'll eventually
just combine teams from different time
periods but surprisingly they ended the
episode with the teams that doesn't
cause that many time aberrations like
it's not like reverse-flash so it's not
like any of them don't have the right to
exist but the time storm prevents them
from getting away so number six it
provides the next opportunity for the
Legion to kill like half of the team
members so you get to have each of the
main characters experience a significant
death of one of their comrades Martin
Stein has to watch a version of Jack's
die vixen has to watch a version of Nate
die just like he had to watch her die so
that sort of informs them later in the
episode being more honest about their
feelings it kind of winds up being there
Dormammu I've come to bargain scene
where you just have multiple deaths from
characters that are the heroes that then
are still alive at the end of the
episode
Oh
yeah
[Music]
for Mama
I come to bargain so shutting them all
down number five the army of reverse
flashes so just to be clear here he
didn't get reverse flashes from all over
the multiverse these are from different
periods in time so with one reverse
flash time aberration is catnip for the
black flash imagine what it's like for
an army of reverse flashes it be a jaws
level feeding frenzy so it was just so
much fun seeing that moment on screen
more flashes than you've ever seen on
screen even on the flash TV show that
was what Marc Guggenheim was boasting
more flashes than you've ever seen on
screen even on the show that's called
the flash so they might top that in a
future season of the flash though
challenge accepted it's kind of their
nod to Grant Morrison's Multiversity
that's a storyline where you have a
bunch of different heroes from different
multiverses forming a multiverse Justice
League so you have a whole team of
flashes from all across the multiverse
it's just a really cool scene on screen
number four
Sarah uses the spear getting to talk to
a version of Laurel it's really the
consciousness of the spear of destiny
that's speaking to her through Laurel so
if you were confused about that that's
not the real version of Laurel it's just
a representation of her the spear
telling her hey you can do anything you
want but no you're probably going to do
the right thing so it was a touching
moment it winds up being good catharsis
for her where she remembers the right
thing to do isn't the things she wants
to do which is bringing Laurel back the
original version of Laurel even though
technically katie cassidy
is going to be a main cast member on
arrow next season so we can talk about
that in another video and I love the
Wizard of Oz Easter Egg so in this
scenario Sarah is Dorothy
she's crash-landed in Oz where
everything is possible she can have
anything she wants but she recognizes
that the right thing to do is to go back
to the real world which you know then
they pass it off to vixen like they have
that moment where she puts the ruby
slippers bit Nate gave her as she
decides to stay on the Waverider so
there was a nice Wizard of Oz thing
going through the episode but number
three we get the black ball
- payoff as Sara uses the spear to D
power the spear she basically used the
Spears powers to turn its powers off and
then because they're doing this at a
previous point in the timeline that
means that the black flash was never
captured so he's free again comes back
kills the reverse-flash in a moment
that's very similar to the season one
ending the colors a little bit different
in the special effects are a little bit
better but what's happening here is that
he's erasing the time aberration but
technically when flashes die they become
part of the Speed Force so I know
everybody's like wait a minute does this
mean the reverse slash is dead and not
coming back absolutely not and there are
a whole bunch of ways to explain how he
could come back in the future and how
he's not dead or another version of him
is still alive the easiest one is that
they completely screw the timeline in
that'll be my number one so I'll explain
that in a second they basically folded
time on itself so everything is all
crazy but remember the most important
reason why the reverse flash is still
around is because of multiverse theory
so it's like the Rick and Morty example
so there's time travel and then there's
interdimensional travel we've seen the
legends we've seen the flash travel
through time but we've also seen them go
to other dimensions where other versions
of the characters exist so the spirit of
destiny just change reality for this
universe it didn't change the entire
multiverse although technically it
should so even though eventually a
version of you bars on will resurface in
this universe technically there's
infinite numbers of you bars on reverse
flashes in the multiverse to come back
so there's any number of ways they could
bring them back on the show but a lot of
that just depends on what their season 3
cast is going to look like and they have
been renewed for season 3 already but
number 2 they return everyone that's
still alive on the Legion captain cold
and damian darhk-- malcolm merlyn to
where the reverse-flash first recruited
them white their memories so they sort
of put the toys back in the toy bin so
you have that really touching moment
with Captain Cold
you're going to become a hero that's
your sentence to do something good to
become a better version of yourself I
like the way they ended that and heat
wave from this season way cooler than
Captain cold from this season even
though technically in the comics I'm not
a big fan of the heatwave character but
what they'd done with them on the TV
show
just light years better than what they
did last season so a couple important
twists happen in this moment before they
head for quote-unquote Aruba and
everything goes sideways rip hunter
leaves the ship so you could take that a
number of ways it's like wait a minute
is he going to be on the show in season
three what might end up happening is
that he's not a main cast member so
he'll appear in a couple episodes but
he's not going to be like a big big
character like he was the past two
seasons and then vixen choosing to stay
on the ship is just a way to show you
that she's going to continue to be a
part of the cast in season three this is
there's a new cast member that will be a
part of the team it's not from the
comics so it'll be like a character
that's part of the DC canon that did not
start out in the comics so you can make
all your theories about that once we
learn some more stuff about season three
I'll do a new video kind of explaining
what's going on with that but number one
the legends get kicked out by a Time
storm they find Los Angeles 2017 is like
this Amala conversion with time
collapsed on itself so you have
dinosaurs you have stuff from the far
future all coexisting in the same moment
so the initial problem for season three
at least is going to be untying the knot
of time that they created with all the
crap that they pulled in the last
episode so there are real consequences I
was happy they address that so let me
know what you guys thought of the
episode but just remember you know
characters that die characters that seem
like they're not on the show anymore if
time is a knot in and of itself think
about how you could run into people from
all over time and space so the future in
the past have collided all in the same
moment here so they can bump into future
versions past versions of characters
that we know it'll be interesting to see
how they approach season 3 but like I
said I'll do another season 3 video when
they announced some more details but
what's going to happen is because the
flash is on break I will do a flash
bonus video soon but agents of shield is
back you guys have been asking for an
episode video for that I've got some new
Rick and Morty I'll try to get
everything out as fast as possible so
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway going on now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video while you wait for
that next video to post you can click
here for the trailer for defenders
there's a viral trailer they just post
it and you can click here for brand new
Rick and Morty thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you
guys in the next video